foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to this edition of bonehead of
the week thanks for sticking with us all
week it's Friday and you know what
Friday means every single Friday that's
bonehead a week on the Tony Michaels
podcast and if you're watching the
replay on the Midas touch Network every
single Friday Friday Friday we have bone
in the week what happens is is you go
vote on Twitter
at Tony Michaels pod or on YouTube on
our YouTube channel at Tony Michaels
podcast on YouTube you vote you decide
who is the bonehead of the week and then
we break it down every single week here
on the Tony Michaels podcast in the
second hour because we broadcast Gabe
every single weekday Monday through
Friday for two full hours so this is
what we do on Friday so if you're on the
Midas touch Network channel subscribe
right now don't forget to do that if
you're watching the replay and also you
can download every single episode on
Apple Spotify Google you can even
download
the bone had a weak in and of itself
just go search the Tony Michaels podcast
subscribe follow us everywhere don't
forget to vote every single Thursday for
bone of the week Gabe who are our
boneheads this week well this week we've
got the insurrectionist wife of Supreme
Court Justice Clarence Thomas Jenny
Thomas we've got the uh quote unquote
judge Eileen Cannon as I like to refer
to her lately and the governor-run death
santis hmm death Satan was actually
Satan that's enough I mean that's the
one that was trending many today names
he does he's an [ __ ] yeah he is an
[ __ ] well you know is that who we
should start with is Rhonda Santas is
that who we should start with here yeah
we could start with Ron I think Ron
DeSantis should go [ __ ] himself and if
you want to get some Rhonda Santos can
go [ __ ] himself merch just go to
store.dtonymichaels.com
this stuff is flying off the shelves and
everyone I
think really likes this this art that we
did so
um go pick up your Rhonda Santas merch
but Rhonda santis
he's dealing with several things here he
was being a bonehead before the
hurricane hit Florida of course right
and he's definitely going to be a
bonehead um in the lead up to it
um but
the one thing I want to say is that
when you expect and I said this all week
this is the third day I've said it if
you expect to vote for a governor who
during Hurricane Sandy while he was a
congressperson he was a congressman then
he was a representative of the State of
Florida
and he had the chance to vote on on
federal leave for hurricanes in New York
and New Jersey for Hurricane Sandy he
voted no
that in and of itself just that thing
should disqualify you
from being a governor anywhere and the
reason why is because
you are the one who actually allocates
those federal funds when they come to
your state and to be a person who would
vote against another state getting it
because oh there's Democrats it live
there
that disqualifies you because it only
says it only says your motives and your
motive is to only give the money to the
people you want to have it you're not
going to do what's right by yourself it
also doesn't include uh just because the
people you want to have it that doesn't
necessarily mean your constituents or
the people that you voted for that's
like I want to pick and choose who I
think should get the money or who should
get the aid or the the FEMA assistance
or what have you uh just because they're
Republican they say oh I don't want to
give it these blue areas or these blue
States or what have you I want to give
it to this red state but within the red
State it's also doesn't mean that
they're going to give it to everyone who
was one of the people that they voted
for constituents so this whole pick and
choose uh I can have it but you can have
it this hypocrisy like it's again it's
the same old thing that Republicans do
every single day and every time there's
a tragedy or some event where where that
state or that county or city or whatever
it is that's run by a Republican and
they say oh [ __ ] we actually need big
government to come in we need help
from our Collective Federal family as
I'll call it
they'll take it then they'll accept a
socialist well they'll accept the the
tax line that goes into the pot and to
have that pot come back over to them
when they really need it but if someone
else needs it they go
[ __ ] yourself not a thing well he's Kosh
he's cautiously optimistic that the
president United States Joe Biden will
do what he's supposed to which Joe Biden
sprung in the action immediately yeah he
didn't even hesitate the administration
didn't even hesitate here and so he's
like there was a forecast of a hurricane
you mean we spend federal dollars to
know that [ __ ] are you kidding me it's
crazy it's crazy that sounds like
socialism Gabe we shouldn't be engaging
in any of that I mean it is forecasting
forecasting that seems that seems a
little a little communist God forbid
Tony that we actually use science to
forecast uh well there's another bad
disaster there's another bad word you
and your bad words
but God forbid we use science and
technology to actually forecast and
predict the pattern and the actual uh
path that something like hurricane or
Ian will take and then say okay we know
where to uh send resources we know where
to have people ready to go to put the
lines back up you know we know where to
make sure to set up our camps with FEMA
to make sure that it's out of the path
and it doesn't you know doesn't get lost
to the hurricane and we're able to have
a safe secure location where people can
go to actually get Aid to get food to
get water to get shelter right
almost kind of sounds Christian like in
the values
easy easy no I don't know don't don't do
that either now you're now you're really
you're really getting no I'm just saying
well let's let's listen to Tucker
Carlson here I mean Tucker Carlson
um talk to Ron DeSantis uh about how
he's cautiously optimistic about the
fact that Joe Biden is already sprung
into action here I don't know what he's
talking about but let's listen
when a natural disaster like this
strikes the state it is it is common
it's I I think it's always the case that
the state receives federal aid given how
politicized things are at the moment are
you confident you're going to get the
federal support Florida needs
so I actually spoke with the president
and he said he wants to be helpful so we
did submit a request for reimbursement
for the next 60 days at 100 percent uh
that's uh significant uh support but
it's a significant storm so we haven't
heard back from it but I'm actually
cautiously optimistic that we do I mean
as you say tucker we live in a very
politicized time but you know when
people are fighting for their lives when
their whole livelihood is at stake when
they've lost everything if you can't put
politics aside for that uh then you're
just not going to be able to so I'll
work with anybody who wants to help the
people of Southwest Florida and
throughout our state
so there you have it
yeah we talked about this yesterday and
I'll repeat my point there is no reason
whatsoever for Ron DeSantis to say well
we submitted our expenses and we are
going to or we we believe we will be
reimbursed for the 60 days up to 100
like
there's no reason
to to try to passively uh passive
aggressively kind of throw Biden and the
federal government under the bus when
they were literally and are still
sending resources and funding to make
sure that Florida has what it needs
to keep everyone safe right to get
people to Safe shelter and to get them
resources that they need but but the
whole fact of Ron DeSantis right now
he's trying to make a dig at one already
had a conversation with Biden and Biden
was like yeah I got you no problem don't
really care if you're red I just care
that you're an American because that's
my job as a president it's the United
States it's a United States exactly I
mean like Obama said we're not a red
we're not a blue we're the United States
of America and and that is something
that Joe Biden definitely brings the
table especially when there is a
catastrophic hurricane coming through
Florida and we want to make sure that
people are safe right well here is here
is Joe Biden uh at FEMA let's see it's
this is a small clip let's see what he
had to say how would you describe your
relationship and your conversation with
Governor DeSantis it's totally
irrelevant but I'll answer it okay in
fact very fine he complement Amen to me
he thanked me for the immediate response
we had he told me how much he
appreciated it said he was extremely
happy with what's going on this is not
about whether or anything having to do
with our disagreements politically this
is about saving people's lives homes and
businesses that's what this is about and
so I've been I've talked to him four or
five times already and it's not a matter
of my disagreements with him on other
items uh you want a lesson on how to be
a leader there it is there it is
and again I expected nothing more or
less from Joe Biden than to
reached the bar of human decency
patriotism and being an American caring
about people that are in the state of
Florida because they're here and he's
the president United States like just
that low bar they are so [ __ ] they we
watched as Donald Trump [ __ ] during the
pandemic tried to [ __ ] on states that he
thought were blue and democrat-run
states and all this nonsense during a
[ __ ] pandemic where millions of
people were dying right he tried to [ __ ]
all over him he's like oh you guys get
some stuff right Jared Kushner was part
of the team that was like oh well we're
all going to choose which states there
the Democrat or Republican that are
great resources they weren't even saying
it out loud they were literally saying
it out loud in front of each other and
here Joe Biden is like look I don't give
a damn rather Rhonda Santos is a
Republican or he's a [ __ ] up Joe Biden
no knows that Rhonda Santos is the
governor of Florida that is what he has
to do he has to work with the governor
of Florida to get them federal aid so
that Governor can then give that Aid to
his State like businesses citizens
property to clean up I mean Joe Biden
understands this and one reason why Gabe
and they they always knock him for this
and I don't really get this they're like
oh he's he was in government for so many
years he knows how it works like okay so
why why is that a bad thing is that's a
bad thing that Joe Biden understands how
disaster relief Works in this moment you
people are bonus and the other thing too
I want to point about this clip
is when Joe Biden says yay call me thank
me he said thanks a lot and he I had
four or five conversations with him
right I I don't begrudge the guy because
he's looking for federal money for his
State he's trying to help his
constituents I want to do the same thing
is to help the people of Florida and
really it shits it shits all over the
idea that Ron DeSantis played on on
Tucker Carlson where he's like you know
he dances around why I had to talk to
the President right right I didn't have
a choice but to talk to the President
right when it is that is the case the
president United States Joe Biden
doesn't have a choice but to talk to the
governor of Florida here and and vice
versa but the absolute projection of Ron
DeSantis and Tucker Carlson there is
telling is telling and when you have Joe
Biden like of course this is what
they're going to do this is what the
federal government does I'm standing at
FEMA I'm just standing at FEMA who is He
is wanting money from and I am not gonna
try to keep him from getting it I'm
gonna try to give him every [ __ ]
penny I possibly can give him it's it's
it's tough the core of it is it's not
political it's just being an empathetic
caring human
that's what it is meanwhile Tucker
Carlson bull a lot of things have been
politicized these days
be a a point just like Joe Biden is like
that's irrelevant there's no reason why
my relationship with him doesn't [ __ ]
matter what I care about is that he has
the funds and the resources to make sure
that he protects the Floridians that are
going through this right this natural
disaster that's that's it that's the
basic that's the bare minimum let me
help you help those in your state and
there should be no politics because
there is no politics around it it's just
again being a human who cares about
other humans novel idea I know I know
novel weird stuff okay who else do we
have on the list we have uh Genie Thomas
the insurrectionist no what happened
serial killer sociopath Ginny Thomas
with that crazy smile that she gave
yesterday yeah we played the video
yesterday should we replay the video of
her walking in is that the one we should
replay is there a video of her saying
that um of course she believes that the
election was stolen and why was the
video that came out I think that was the
I think I know I know there's like
people people talking afterwards okay
well here's here apparently seems to be
a picture oh that's the wrong one but
that seems to be a picture Genie
Clarence Thomas
um
oh my god
oh
she's election denier and um the smug
look on her face in this video and the
absolute smartassery in this video like
I'm better than you and I won't be held
a cannibal type attitude then just watch
you'll see
Miss Thomas why do you feel like you
need to speak to the committee to clear
your name
in here did you speak with your husband
if your beliefs of the election being
stolen
thank you for your question I look
forward to answering members
oh there is nothing creepier than
somebody smiling and very quietly
speaking this isn't like an ASMR video
kind of thing she's like thank you for
asking your question thank you thank you
for being here for being here like it's
so glad you're here
it is it is it is super creepy super
creepy almost like she's a robot in a
skin suit or something right I have no
idea I mean it's just like is this like
um the original version of Jared Kushner
like he's an upgrade or some [ __ ] this
is weird the other thing that I didn't
notice till just now she has a cane did
you notice that yeah I I well I didn't
see it but I heard that right I didn't
know I didn't notice it the other day
when I want because I watched this
several times trying to figure out like
who these people were and what because
it was hard to even kind of determine
what she says because the last line she
says is I am looking forward to
answering that question
never is what I think she says I'm
looking forward to answering that
question
I look forward to overthrowing the
government
like I I look forward to skinning you
alive later like that is that's the vibe
I get it's a Dahmer bike oh yeah huge
dommer Vibe well
it's not surprising that Jeannie Thomas
after she went and talked not under Ode
to the January 6 committee she came out
and I guess it was an interview or
something where she said no I totally
believe that the election was stolen
like she even even the act of her going
in to try to clear her and her husband's
name in front of the select committee
didn't convince her that she possibly
should say in public but here's the
thing
my guess is
she has to keep this facade up
because if Jeannie Thomas went out in
public and said of course Donald Trump
lost of course Joe Biden it was all
[ __ ] right Donald Trump would turn
on her in a minute we'll turn on her in
a minute and they just can't afford that
they just can't afford that because what
if that Messiah becomes king again he
might just save them so they can't they
can't turn on him yet
um in public at least in private like
Bill Barr did and several others now
Bill Barr did it in private with the
select committee and then they played
this [ __ ] out loud and Trump turned on
him and Bill Barr's like okay well if
that's what you're gonna do I'm gonna
roast you on this documents thing so
speaking speaking of the documents
oh man we got some documents yeah we
were gonna make Donald Trump one of the
contestants right in that right but it
would have been the same slate is that
right it would have been the same one as
last week that's crazy because last week
it was Ronda santis was on for uh
trafficking uh humans Venezuelan
migrants to uh Martha's Vineyard right
Eileen Cannon again doubling down and
saying that uh Trump should not have to
do what he has to do which is he broke
the law and has to face the consequences
and then also uh Donald Trump we had on
there because I think just related to
the documents and said hey well I mean
he's he's just like world-class
bone-headedry I mean it's just it
doesn't stop right like he just he won't
quit he won't quit the moan headed three
so he ended up being the dishonorable
mention yeah because we wanted to give
someone else a shot and that's why we
threw Jeannie Thomas she didn't have a
chance though no against some designs
honestly you know I said it I tweeted
out this morning I said judge again in
quotes quote-unquote judge judge Eileen
Cannon wanted to be famous
but now she's Infamous
oh she is an Infamous bonehead but the
reason why I think we put Donald Trump
on here is because a video we played the
other day where he's in his office
uh-huh
while hurricane Ian is taking place I
actually had a there are a couple uh
Publications course he's on the other
side of the state right he's on the
unfortunately or unfortunately however
you know he's on the other estate and
you know the path kind of goes goes
through it doesn't really hit uh the
area of Palm Beach Mar-A-Lago he's fine
Ian missed the assignment really
honestly he was like you know whatever
oops Yeah
uh I shared a video online that actually
picked up a lot of steam and it was
found its way on different like
Publications which I was really
surprised about but it's the it's the
the lack of
or rally it's just a tone deaf response
while a natural disaster is happening in
the very state
that you're making this video from while
people are suffering losing their homes
people are dying he decides the best use
of his time is not to say hey
let's raise money
on behalf of those who are who are
victims of this hurricane
instead he says Ah you guys I got this
really important deadline happening at
the end of September to make sure that
my quarter three financials don't look
like dog [ __ ] because the August did
well how much did he raise in August how
much money because it had to be a lot of
money in terms of just not compared to
what we would think no no it was it was
the number that he raised in the month
of August is four
zero forty thousand four forty forty
forty million just just forty forty
dollars
forty dollars wait wait so like one zero
did Eric did Eric give forty dollars to
get his dad's attention you know that is
hard I've read through the financial
statements for the last few months of
his Super Pac and I I can't identify hmm
who's that for donors were obviously
super weird it almost feels like they
can't charge credit cards or something
like they're yeah they're they don't
have their credit card machine to
process cards here
here's a whistle lips here
um giving his little he's begging for
money let's let's watch we have a
minute oh you do and there's no
there's never ever nobody has never been
so disrespected our country has never
been so low certainly in the minds of
others and especially the leaders of
other countries what lead I know over
the world we have to change it we have
to bring our country back we made
America great and now we're going to
have to make America great again you
sure this ain't from 2016.
you can do help out we have to meet the
deadline the midterms are coming up it's
going to be one of the most important
elections in the history of our country
so I hope you can help out and help out
we really appreciate it and good luck
so he's saying here that we you should
help with the midterms by not giving to
the candidates but giving to his
personal slush fund is that yeah when
I'm taking it yeah and and here's the
thing little to no money has been given
to any of these candidates running in
the midterms so he's trying to uh he's
piggybacking on the midterms are
approaching so he's like we gotta get
this money in now we got to get this
money in for the midterms but really the
money is being used to pay off his legal
bills well I mean I'm not saying that
you know I'm not for this I mean if
they're going to give money to someone
I'd rather they give money to spend on
his legal defense where he's going to
lose than a candidate that could win I'm
just saying I'm just saying then that's
why Donald Trump got dishonorable
mention because he's [ __ ] broke he
can't even squeeze together 50 bucks
holy [ __ ] he can't even squeeze together
50 bucks uh what happened with our Alpha
guck here Jordan Peterson was training
this morning on Twitter what do we got
here
found his way on um he looks like a
Pierce Morgan doesn't he
say again he does look like an incel
King here doesn't he yeah I mean under
the tears of the incel king will he was
crying
he was crying he was crying I don't have
this clip I was gonna try to cut it I
was supposed to try to get deep but but
do you have the YouTube clip in the in
the timestamp right yeah yeah I got the
yeah I'll get that so basically the
context here is that Jordan Peterson
went on to Pierce Morgan uncensored or
whatever the new show is oh another in
silk in another and sell Lord Pierce
Morgan uncensored so uh is this the same
show where he interviewed Donald Trump
and they were like trying to you know oh
yeah they were you know patting each
other on the back and then Pierce Morgan
challenged him on one question Donald
Trump he was got up like a crybaby and
left because he couldn't handle is that
the same show I believe that's the
second show okay that's after he that's
after he left the uh the
um the good morning right right in
Britain okay yeah yeah uh advertised
so this is the clip where uh the
question is basically Olivia Wilde and
he'll give context but Olivia Wilde says
that Jordan Peterson is the leader of
the incels right what's my time what's
my time stamp here yeah it's the full
clip oh okay it leads into it I mean he
kind of goes on afterward but afterwards
okay I thought that there was a I
thought there was a time stamp here oh
that was the longer one from the spot
okay okay so there's a full version but
this is the the abbreviated version
let's listen
I've got to wrap it up I don't want to
but I have to I want to ask you just
quickly uh the film director Olivia
Wilde has a new movie out which she says
it's based on you this insane man this
pseudo-intellectual hero to the in-cell
community in cell being these weirdo
loner men yeah uh who are despicable in
many ways is that you are you the
intellectual hero to these people
foreign
okay it really is Rich to watch Pierce
Morgan call in cells like as if he
doesn't know that a [ __ ] ton of his
little his little following is a bunch
of these [ __ ] incels like these Elon
stands even oh my God come on come on
Pierce and then you ask him are you that
because I thought I was that are you is
it you or is it me I can't I can't
remember
why not you know
um
people have been after me for a long
time by because I've been speaking to
disaffected young men you know what a
terrible thing to do that is oh my God
foreign
[Applause]
oh my god listen listen I'm a white dude
I'm a white dude in America I'm not
marginalized no one has ever repressed
me it's it's not a thing Jordan Peterson
not a [ __ ] especially someone who
comes off as an elitist intellectual
right who goes
I believe any Canadian he's not even
American he's Canadian I believe he's
gonna and I'm not trying to toss stones
at Canada I'm just saying that he's not
a a Canadian he's not he's not even
people right and he's he's more popular
in America than he is up there because
they don't really play that nonsense up
there right but this idea that the
[ __ ] [ __ ] white dudes a bunch of
white dudes in this country are
oppressed and [ __ ] and they're the
marginalized can you get the [ __ ] out of
here oh my God you're pointing out
you're pointing out white people's
privilege how dare you oppress them get
the [ __ ] out of here
this is the same guy who also and I
think I can find a clip here well I
wanna I wanna I wanna play him crying
here I gotta believe I want to watch him
cry let's let's watch him cry
it's making you emotional talk about it
well God you know
oh God you know very difficult to
understand
many young men are in that category
um
casual
insults these these in cells is what
does it mean it's like well these men
they're they don't know how to make
themselves attractive to women who are
very picky and good for them women like
be picky that's that's your gift okay
I'm not gonna let him dig yeah pull any
deeper than he's got it here the reason
why these people think this way is
because of Jordan Peterson and people
like him the reason why white trumped up
white dudes think they're marginalized
and oppressed is because of people like
Jordan Peterson
they [ __ ] brainwashed them into
thinking that equality
to the oppressor is oppression this is
all bone-headedry it's it's just dumb
[ __ ] and it's laughable on its face
it's really ridiculous is there another
clip you want to show this I want to
show a clip it's just to give people
full time
yeah yeah oh man this is not the first
time he's ever cried but the clip that I
just sent you will give people context
for anyone who doesn't know who Jordan
Peterson is because
yeah if this wasn't a take to say wow
that gives me an idea of who he is it's
definitely gonna be this next take where
Jordan Peterson is on Joe Rogan and
talks about
black skin color and how he's not right
here's another lord of the incels uh Joe
Rogan and it's the same [ __ ] these
people wouldn't think they're
marginalized it wouldn't be crying about
their oppression that doesn't exist
right if it weren't for [ __ ] like this
let's listen depending on who you ask
either you're a voice of reason and
rationality and
and uh you know a personal
responsibility or he couldn't even
hardly get it out did you notice that he
couldn't even hardly come up with the
words yeah what is it called what what
is this weird thing okay or you're a
voice of intolerance and bigotry and
anger and hateful sexual oppression
Prejudice Dyson call you and meaning
every white man yeah and and a mean
angry white man hilarious exactly you're
not mean at all that's what's dumb about
that statement it's you're not mean at
all I am white actually that's a lie too
I'm kind of tan and he was actually not
bad
oh [ __ ] I'm darker than you yeah it's
ridiculous yeah but neither of us are
white well I'm Italian and he was brown
not black well isn't that weird yeah
it's really weird black and white thing
is so strange because the shades are tan
and brown there's such a spectrum of
shades of people okay I can't I can't I
can't I can't it we've done this video
but before I think we've done this video
two or three times because these [ __ ]
bonuses just
I mean it's a video that will never get
an old and it will always show you who
these people are right specifically
Jordan Peterson trying to make some
claim that I'm not actually white uh
he's he's not saying he's brown like
what he's saying is I'm oppressed
because of my skin colors she's like hey
White is my shirt which is kind of like
this weird off-white but he's like I'm
I'm not white guys so like I'm not the
bully and I'm not the villain here I'm
actually an off-white I'm like an
eggshell white I'm like a white that you
might go to Home Depot and say I don't
really want fresh egg color right but I
want like a hint of some color in there
just to show people that I'm not
actually this do you think he did the 23
and me and he is just pure white yeah I
think when they're white and there's no
people usually people like they have
something like sub-Saharan African right
this and this and it's just like 100
no no no way to doubt it just white
there it is Peterson is wider than you
know than the powder that goes up Donald
Trump Junior's nose we couldn't even
tell you if you're British Irish
Scottish like anything over there you're
like we couldn't even tell if you're
like from from any you're like uh you
know oh your heritage is the Vikings or
anything right you know white right it
just came it just said on this 23andMe
damn you white damn you white
100.
you're white
um which
oh man I gotta finish up here on this
bonehead of the week I hate to get off
Jordan Peterson though but but we got to
go to another bonehead
who thinks she has privilege here um her
name is Judge Eileen Cannon everyone
famously are infamously as you said
earlier knows her now is the judge who
has really shitty legal takes this is
very awkward for a federal judge who is
supposed to know what they're doing Gabe
it's really awkward it's really strange
to watch a federal judge not know
anything about uh Federal judging at all
you know the rule of law their job
because here's what happened real and
because
um I don't even know if we don't have
video over because she won't even allow
video or anything in her courtroom right
because she didn't want people to see
what she's doing so here's the thing
Trump asked for a special Master which
is boneheaded in and of itself
he decides that that's a good idea then
Trump recommends judge Deary in the
eastern district of New York who is kind
of a no-nonsense judge who is on the
fisa court that issued the warrant and
the the the wiretapping of Carter page
who was part of the Trump campaign in
2016 and the right wing hates that ah
look it's corruption
and the doj says oh you're going to
recommend that judge we'll take him
we'll make him the special master that
sounds great
judge Eileen Cannon says fantastic I'm
gonna appoint him as the special Master
Deary does the thing that Eileen Cannon
should have done when the Motions
entered her Court When Donald Trump
wanted a special Master she should have
said you were making all these claims
are these claims true that's what that's
the bare minimum and judge Deary was
kind of doing her job through the
special Master position now Donald
Trump's team did not like that because
they want to be able to lie in public
that is that is what they're doing this
has nothing to do with the criminal case
this has nothing to do with the criminal
investigation the doj is not going to
stop their criminal Vision investigation
or stop a grand jury from indicting him
this special Master thing is all
distraction and all nonsense it's all
delay tactics but the thing that Trump's
lawyers know and that Eileen Cannon
knows is that if if Trump does what
diary wants him to do is Trump can't
then go out in public looking say the
opposite of what they filed in court now
Trump can he'll [ __ ] lie no matter
what but when I say Trump I mean his
team his defense his defense here his
legal team if they file in court in a
motion with a special master that no
that planet evidence thing that's a lie
there's no Planet evidence he did not
declassify these things they cannot
claim that in court they know it she
knows it he knows it Grandpa Poopypants
knows it that Deary is really
challenging any defense he has here
because it's not a defense it's not one
planted evidence that wasn't planned is
not a defense I Declassified with my
[ __ ] Big Mac stained hands or my mind
is not a defense yeah they're my
documents not the government's documents
it's not a defense because it's not real
it's all wise so it's not offense so
judge Eileen Cannon here decides what
she's gonna do is now become the special
master
and do and tell the special Master you
can't do that because that's oppression
towards you know marginalized white men
especially Rich billionaires who grew up
with a silver spoon who've never been
hell accountable for anything in their
entire life you just can't do that yeah
that's what I am I am I way off here is
that the story here no I mean basically
uh Eileen Cannon became Trump's defense
attorney like that's what's happening
right when she's given the opportunity
then she will say oh well we need to
protect no he doesn't have to say these
things or commit these things under oath
because that would cause I don't know
perjury right be lying right it would go
against him and you know like I think I
think it takes aim at the lawyers more
than it does Trump because Trump he
doesn't give a [ __ ] the lawyers have to
acknowledge like look
there's the there's a
there's the phrase Maca right which has
now been associated with make attorneys
get attorneys and this is especially
true right now because now what Trump is
doing is he's making these attorneys
he's putting them in a position
to say
okay you guys you guys know what
happened and you have to lie for it
which would then violate what they have
you know made a a promise to when they
were accepted when they were given their
their law license actually practice law
so
they're they're getting in a very
interesting position too like Trump can
lie sure whatever but now these lawyers
are are putting their own careers at
risk because they would then be also
lying right under oath
and uh under the under this
investigation to say oh yeah well you
know well several of them have backed
away because there's like there's no way
I'm gonna get caught up in this idea
then I'm gonna lose my wealth my way of
life my well-being because you want me
to lie for you on a court motion you're
a dumbass no way and that's what is
happening with Deering that's where
Eileen Gannon has done the bone edit
Thing by covering for Trump and his
legal team because they can't cover
their own ass because he's in hot water
here he's in deep [ __ ] and she knows it
dearie knows it the legal team knows it
Trump knows it because he knows what he
did right and it's criminal I mean
what's gonna happen is the same thing
that happened with the 100 100
classified documents right you were
going to say oh okay fine we'll appeal
this decision and then it goes to the
court and the court says yeah you're
[ __ ] idiot why would you even say
that right and then what happened last
time was she said nope he gets to keep
these documents so they held him off
then they went to the uh the ninth
circuit or the 11th circuit and they he
said oh you're an idiot right now you
can have these documents and then she
was like okay you guys are right and now
she's come back to say okay cool I'm
gonna make sure that you know and then
she goes forward with what she what
she's done right now which is around
making certain statements or not having
to and pushing the pushing the the the
the case out further till December I
think so is your prediction hearing that
uh if this because from my understanding
I'm not a lawyer everyone should go
listen to Ben Marcellus on this more
than me uh but um from Midas Touch you
can get it here on the Midas touch
network if you're watching the replay of
bone end of the week
um analysis of every single motion but I
I believe that that emotion kind of that
doj has to kind of wait for something to
file a motion to appeal to the um the
11th circuit but it likely will be
overturned but here's the thing about
the criminal case this this special
Master nonsense has nothing to do with
the criminal investigation right not a
goddamn thing the only thing that this
is is that dispute here is what
documents are what and the fact of the
matter is the Department of Justice has
already done this work has already done
this work and Deary knows that that's
why he's asking these questions to get
them to just adhere to facts inside of a
courtroom that's all he's trying to
adjust to get them to do the legal team
to adhere to facts so that they can
frame up a factual defense which they do
not have that's the main thing here and
Eileen Cannon knows it and that's what
made her to bonehead of the week my
prediction was not her but you guys
voted for her and that's what happens in
democracy you lean into it you vote you
decide we break it down let's give
Eileen judge quote unquote Eileen Gannon
her moment of boneheadness
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you judge Eileen Gannon for being
an hour
our winner of Bonet of the week you
certainly are boneheaded I would bet
that this is not the last time she's
gonna show up on this no I'm telling you
once this is the once they file this
it's gonna get appealed it's gonna go to
the 11th circuit she's gonna be back on
bone end of the week and they're gonna
be like is she gonna be three weeks in a
row is she gonna be three weeks in a row
holy [ __ ] she gets on it next week
that'll be three three weeks in a row
damn right now she's heating up that's
right that's right next week she's on
fire dude that's right she's on fire so
every Friday don't forget to come watch
the Tony Michaels podcast watch bonehead
live in the second hour and also watch
on the replay on Midas Touch network if
you're on Midas Touch Network right now
subscribe to the minus touch Network and
don't forget to go over the Tony
Michaels podcast YouTube channel And
subscribe there help us out give us some
Support also follow us on at Tony
Michaels pod because you can vote for
bone end of the week on Twitter and
YouTube you vote you decide we break it
down every single week
what a bone end of the week it did not
go the way I thought it was gonna go but
you know that's just how it works the
votes fall we certify them we present
them to the public
here no trying to influence the uh the
voting that's happening like Jenny
Thomas no stop we play fair we let you
guys decide that's right bonehead of the
week thank you everyone for joining us
if you're on the Tony Michaels podcast
stick around we got some announcements
after the song if you're on the minus
touch Network join us next week on
bonehead of the week foreign
[Music]
[Applause]